welcome to the third episode in our
recurring series of two guest podcasts
this episode is all about games join us
as we follow ideas from the far out what
if world of MSRs gaming research to the
far reaching here's what world of
Microsoft's Xbox gaming franchise and
see from the perspectives of both a
research executive and a gaming
executive how ideas collide worlds come
together and everybody has fun you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using dr. Chris Bishop is
a Microsoft technical fellow and
director of MSR Cambridge where he
oversees an impressive portfolio of
research including machine learning AI
healthcare and gaming Phil Spencer is
the executive vice president of gaming
at Microsoft where he oversees
everything from the design of the next
Xbox console to the creation and release
of blockbuster properties like Halo
Gears of War and Forza Motorsport these
two powerhouse executives are pushing
the boundaries of creativity technical
innovation and fun across the spectrum
of gaming genres and devices for nearly
2 billion gamers around the world on
today's podcast Chris and Phil discussed
their respective roles in Microsoft's
gaming ecosystem revealing a sort of
enrichment pipeline that flows all the
way from researcher to developer to
gamer they also give us an inside look
at the close collaboration between the
world-class research organization of MSR
and the world-class gaming franchise of
Xbox highlighting Microsoft's unique
ability to deliver the tools talent and
resources that fuel innovation and help
shape the future of gaming that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
so we have a dynamic duo in the booth
today for a special two guest episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast I'm
sitting here with Chris Bishop who is a
Microsoft technical fellow and director
of Microsoft Research in Cambridge UK
and I've got Phil Spencer who's the
executive vice president of gaming at
Microsoft and he leads the company's
business across all gaming devices and
services that's right yeah and I am the
duo part Chris he's dynamic I am duo
welcome Chris and Phil Joel and Chris
great yes yeah it's awesome thanks I'd
like to start on sort of a philosophical
note to give us a framework for our
topic today from the cultural historian
Johan Huizinga whom I share a last name
with he famously said play is older than
culture and uber nanny Mary Poppins from
your home town Chris famously said you
find the fun and snap the jobs a game so
we seem hardwired to play from each of
your perspectives what's so important
about games or play that a company like
Microsoft would invest so much both in
research and product teams in this area
Chris maybe you could start us out sure
from a research point of view games
offer an amazing environment in which to
develop new machine learning algorithms
and techniques and of course we hope in
due course those new algorithms or
feedback not only into gaming but into
many other domains but beyond the sort
of the very technical machine learning
techniques themselves there's also the
fact that gaming is an environment in
which we can explore the relationship
between AI and people and see how that
can work in partnership so it's a very
rich environment in which to drive new
research ideas Phil what about you I
think adding on that what I would say as
you said we look at play as an innate
human need it's something that we all do
Microsoft's mission statement of empower
every person not only is what we build
but actually finding audience for the
things that we build so to me the nice
thing about gaming is
it is so pervasive people play on any
device you know give me five minutes and
a piece of paper and I'll get bored and
start playing tic-tac-toe with myself or
something and I think as we look at the
application to empower everybody finding
human uses of technology that really can
reach anybody regardless of demographic
regardless of where you live regardless
of socio-economic situation I just think
really opens up the opportunity for us
as a company yeah I have to ask at the
outset what's your personal relationship
to gaming and why are you interested in
this area personally I think yet my
all-time greatest gaming experience was
actually playing a fantastic game called
portal with my sons and really
discovering that amazing social
connection that it brings it's it's very
collaborative game puzzle solving
together and just great father-son
experience of course that said they're a
little bit more experienced to be with
the Xbox controllers three orders of
magnitude faster than me but it was
still good fun they have an unfair
advantage for me I teasingly say that I
think it's the only job that Satya would
hire me for at the company I don't think
I'm kind of equipped to do anything else
but I think Chris hit right on it some
of my best experiences with my family
have been around play I have two
daughters some of my best friendships
have been around this opportunity I
started playing with my father he was an
engineer brought a PC home and then I
look out there today there are so many
forces in our lives that try to create
division between people the other enough
people you're of this I'm of that and
this is an art form in gaming that has a
natural capability to bring people
together in a cooperative social way to
either win the round to compete in a
nice way with each other and I just love
that I love that I can work in a space
that has this ability to bring people
together and it's the thing that drives
me kind of personally in this space
Chris you are on the podcast earlier
this year and we didn't talk much about
gaming turns out you're overseeing some
pretty cool research and gaming
applications which we'll talk about in a
minute but first tell us why gaming is a
sweet spot for the cambridge lab and
what your vision is with gaming
technology research that's a great
question I mean the Cambridge lab has
been around for more than 20
is and throughout that time we've been
very fortunate in having a incredibly
close collaboration with Xbox and that's
led to a number of pieces of technology
actually getting out there into the real
world and you know one of the factors I
think is just that we have a lot of
enthusiastic gamers in the lab and you
know in research part of what we're
supposed to do is to come up with new
ideas we're not directed we're supposed
to be kind of spontaneous and I think a
little bit out of the box and so people
naturally combine their passions are
excited about technologies like machine
learning and many others and they're
excited about games and they want to
bring those two together so I think
that's been one of the factors for sure
we really I think uniquely placed in
having this great research strength but
also being really the only company in
that space with a you know gaming
division and so it's just kind of an
unfair advantage we have and it'd be
crazy not to take part of it Phil you
have a classic version of the mailroom
to boardroom story here at Microsoft you
started as an intern and now you're the
EVP of gaming tell us how you've seen
the company's position in gaming evolved
over the years and give us your vision
as to where you see it going in the
future yeah I started at Microsoft in
1988 as a programming intern from the
University of Washington go dogs go dogs
and it was interesting like many things
that Microsoft started that were new to
us back in the day some of it was driven
out of a paranoia of what competitors
might be doing
I mean Xbox was really born out of this
fear that somebody else was going to
create a family room PC that if we
should lean in and we should go do that
as a company the thing I love about
where we are in gaming today we sit on
the senior leadership team satya senior
leadership team or one of the key
pillars of the company is let's aspire
to how do we show empathy how do we
empower how do we use Microsoft as a
platform for us and the things that we
want to do and I love that drive as a
company and I just think we've made it
through the oh no somebody else might do
it too the thinking about what we might
be able to do and us aspiring on our own
I'd say the partnership with Chris's
team and Microsoft Research has been so
critical to that and it's nice to
see how the company's rallying around
the interests that Microsoft all app has
in the gaming category what's
fascinating is I've got a classic
research person here and a classic
product person and I don't know if it's
historic or traditional separation of
streams as it were don't cross the
streams but research and products have
tended to stay in their lanes that said
I think there's actually quite a lot of
collaboration going on that people maybe
don't know about and it seems to be
gaining traction now so do you see a
sort of enhanced momentum between the
academic and the industry teams and if
so why do you think that is Chris maybe
you could yeah I think there's always
been great collaboration actually if it
hasn't always been so visible but I
think there is a sense of sort of more
collaboration than ever and I think part
is just the sort of the pace of
innovation and I think there's also more
excitement in research particularly
these days around seeing the fruits of
that research really impacts the real
world and you know one of the great
privileges of being at Microsoft is you
can do great research and then you can
get that research out to hundreds of
millions of people and that's very tough
to do that in a university environment
for example and so I think you know more
than ever there's a real enthusiasm
about very close collaboration yeah how
about you fell from the product
perspective what's important about
collaborating with these guys well we'd
probably don't talk about it publicly
enough but Chris's team is our secret
ingredient when we look at the
competition in our space in gaming the
decade-plus that we have working
together with Microsoft Research and the
Xbox team and gaming around making it
more fun making it easier to find people
that you're gonna have fun with safety
and security online something we're
focusing a lot on right now I just think
it's so critical to get people who have
a sole focus like the MSR teams do on
these categories present a problem in
areas where we're not actually sure what
the solution might be or even what it
might entail and to kind of check in
every so often and see the progress that
they can make I'm really both in awe of
the team and the capability that Chris
has and the impact that they have on the
business that we're trying to drive well
let's talk about some of the specific
examples of what happens when research
and product come together
I've had some pretty cool folks on this
podcast and they've brought some pretty
cool research to the gaming world Lenin
Rabindranath sibling Ham has talked with
me about hype zone and nikunj Raghavan
she has just been in the booth to talk
about triton and i encourage our
listeners to hit up those podcasts
because it's a deeper dive on the
research but phil for a second from the
product perspective talk about how
things like hype zone and triton are
impacting your world
yeah hype zone I think is a great
example to Center on we have a streaming
service called mixer there are hundreds
of millions of people now who watch
video games getting played and I know to
some that might seem strange I kind of
go back to the birth of like ESPN where
you were gonna have a television channel
that only had highlights of sports and
life and how that will never work
things like twitch things like mixer are
examples of this for the next generation
of people coming up where it is their
Sports Center it's the place they go the
personalities they follow so we have
this service called mixer and it was
again one of these what-if scenarios
well how do you know what streamed watch
how do you know where the most
interesting things are happening you
know hype zone we kind of borrowed the
name from red zone from the NFL of the
most interesting game that's on right
now and there's a computer vision
machine learning algorithm running on
all of our streams across the games that
have hype zone and they're actually
looking for the most interesting moment
at that time live and you can sit on the
hypes own channel and literally we will
swap to the most interesting instance of
that game on our service and it is about
bringing the fun to somebody in an easy
way but also when you think about the
inroads that we make and you start
thinking about the applicability beyond
just game streaming what about news on
the Internet do I follow one news
service or do I have something that
knows what I like and is able to watch
all the streams and bring those to me if
it's recommendations on something like
YouTube there's something I think
there's a lot of applicability for this
kind of tech which in so many areas and
the things that we invest in gaming is
great I think we're always looking at
how it applies to gaming but then also
how it applies to the planet
of course how is it that you sort of
think ahead of the curve as it were
before it hits product what kind of
research paths you'll follow because
this could have fruit in this doesn't
it's got to be difficult it's a great
question because research is sort of
this common rhetorically infinite space
of possibility and the question is no
where should you look and I you know
often say the researchers you know the
biggest part of their job is figuring
out what research to do and then the
rest is kind of doing it is almost not
the easy part but it you know doing the
right thing at the right time not going
up to something it's so impossible or so
far out it will never be real but also
just steering clear of kind of the
incremental stuff trying to do the thing
which kind of sounds impossible and a
couple years later you actually land it
that's sort of the sweet spot that
stimulation of you know brainstorming
about the impossible and getting ideas
and thinking well maybe that isn't so
impossible now I've got the kind of an
idea I could have a go at that or
something like that's actually very
stimulating for researchers in terms of
thinking about what they should be
working on next
[Music]
one of the biggest challenges in online
gaming and in pickup basketball if we're
honest disappointing players that are at
your own level because everyone wants a
good game right and apparently
algorithms can help us find similar
players talk about this new skills
ranking system called true skill Phil
what is it and where is it being used
and how's it working out so I'm gonna
expand that a little bit because I think
the fundamental issue that you talk
about really in any activity is how do I
find the group of people that I'm gonna
feel most comfortable with and have the
most fun or even achieve the most if
it's something that's more work-related
true skill for us in the pure gaming
space is like having the AI analyze how
somebody plays and what their capability
is and then when you go in to play
another game and you say I want to have
a good game I want to play against
people that I'm fairly evenly matched
with we're able to use our understanding
of your capability and put you in a
match with similar skilled people but at
the same time it's not just the skill of
the player its what about what language
these people use when they play are the
aggressive players are they not
aggressive players there's hours of the
day even something as simple as that
that I want to play and I don't want to
play trueskill starts with your
capability and builds from that but the
layering on on top of this of the social
dynamics that happen online that aren't
just about the skill someone has but
also when I'm there I feel like this is
an environment where I can show up as my
true self I can be most authentic and
have a good time at the same time and
when I think about that that applies in
so many places in our world today right
it's the social interactions that we
have on so many of these social networks
and other things I think the work that
we're doing together in that space is
awesome and I think there's just so much
opportunity there Chris could you add to
that from the research perspective
because he's talking about AI algorithms
that are watching me play
sure I mean it's a super interesting
piece of technology true skill because
you know a lot of the work we're doing
machine learning uses techniques like
neural nets and deep learning and
they're very sort of data hungry and
they're amazingly powerful techniques
but true skill is a really interesting
showcase of a different approach to
machine learning called model-based
machine learning or probabilistic
modeling and really the secret there is
the you instead of having this big sort
of black box that you train up with lots
of data instead you actually describe
the process by which the data comes into
being you say well here's one person
they play against another person and
there's a game outcome that's the data
we observe and then you run some you
know complicated code corresponding some
beautiful math score Bayes theorem and
it takes all the information you have
about players and their skills and it
absorbs the new information of the game
outcome and then kind of updates this
skill evaluation and it's all done in a
way that takes into account uncertainty
so probability is sort of at the heart
of all of this and you know just one of
the first really large-scale
applications of this kind of machine
learning it went out first in halo it's
not part of Gears of War 4 and we're now
thinking about how we make this very
generic so it can apply to a really
broad range of games well Chris aside
from gaming other researchers that
you're working with are bringing gaming
technology to healthcare and to more
guests on the podcast Cecily Morrison
spearheaded project Torino which makes a
programming language for children with
visual disabilities and high and young
was recently on talking about several
projects including physio which makes a
video game out of laborious cystic
fibrosis breathing exercises for kids
talk about the vision behind the
research that crosses these borders I
mean this is such an exciting area I
think we're really just scratching the
surface I mean projects like I mean
mentioned they'd the probably call it
Torino internally by now we've done a
royalty-free license to an organization
that's going to produce this as code
jumper and it's just a beautiful idea of
allowing initially kids who are blind or
partially sighted to learn to code by
having effectively each line of code is
represented as this very tactile plastic
object that you connect to other plastic
objects using wires and then you press a
button and the code gets executed but
actually the really nice thing about
this is
it turns out to be a great way for kids
who have full vision also to learn to
code and it's really inclusive because
you know the blind kids and that the
sighted kids can get together and work
together collaboratively to design code
and change code and so on I'm just
really excited that's out there in the
world man yeah and what about physio
that I mean when high n was on the
podcast I was like that's incredible
how did that find its way into research
sometimes really hard to kind of trace
the sort of ancestry of these ideas you
know think of it a building you know put
coffee in one end and other ideas come
out the other and there's this
mysterious sort of organic process that
happens in between it is actually the
fuel for creative when both coffee
machines break it's a media machine
that's the most critical well along
those lines Phil millions of people saw
and were deeply moved by Microsoft's
powerful Super Bowl ad this year about
making gaming accessible for everyone
the tagline when everyone plays we all
win is perfect because it's true
disabilities don't reduce our desire to
play so tell us the story behind the new
adaptive controller for gamers with
disabilities because this is another
area of your oversight with just the
hardware that people use to play yeah I
love the story of the adaptive
controller not just because of the
product that we were able to build but
really the team that started this it
started as a hackathon project inside of
Microsoft of people coming together on
their own time not all from the gaming
organization again similar taking a well
what if we tried to help in this space
there have been a lot of third parties
that had done some form of accessible
controllers prices were very high there
were no standards so we took the
approach if we could create a piece of
hardware basically sell it at what it
gots to build make it accessible to any
other platform so it's out there for
Windows it's out there for Xbox we've
sent it to every other competing gaming
platform saying hey here's a base to
go use but the team after the hackathon
project did this in the evenings got it
to a point where they brought it to our
game leadership team we looked at the
product we weren't sure how we were
gonna be able to fund it how do you
market that what is it gonna mean when
it comes out when you start that journey
with that community it's not a one step
journey so if we're in this we're in it
for the long run it's not a PR beat for
us as the product beat and then it was
really nice in the holidays to see one
when it first shipped in September how
the gaming community worked through some
of the agencies that really helped us
with testing and feedback to put it out
and then there was a Microsoft ad that
they put out with Owen who's the star of
the ad great kid and you just see him
light up but I will say you talked about
when everyone plays we all win the
moment that gets to me the most I hear
this so many times is when Owens dad is
talking about Owen playing video games
the truest representation of Owen is
when he's playing online
he's just Owen he's not in a chair he
can decide how and when he wants to
share who he is
because everybody else he's a good gamer
and I love that I think the line the dad
uses something like you know when he's
online playing he's just like everybody
else and I hear that so often in our
space that the more we make it
accessible it just brings more people
and everyone can play then something
Chris hit on which I also think is
really important for us on the product
side to think about almost every
instance where we've approached making
our products more accessible whether
it's to sight hearing impaired people we
make the product better for everybody
yes it's actually not an either/or
decision so that it doesn't surprise me
at all that programming techniques that
we would put in place for somebody whose
site challenged becomes accessible to
other people we've seen that we've seen
that our text-to-speech work that we've
done on console and it's such a truism
we have to believe that when you make
things easier for somebody literally
make it easier for everybody yeah and in
fact Cecily was talking quite
extensively about the fact that you can
have situational disabilities you may
have two arms but you're holding a baby
and doing something with your phone
you're suddenly a one-armed phone user
yeah and things like that the curb cut
for wheelchairs is also good for cycle
lists and it goes way process right
that's right it's just expanding the
aperture of how you're thinking and you
can't always do that because your own
situation doesn't always give you the
life experience so Chris on that same
line what's the vision in terms of this
accessibility thread kind of adding on
what Phil said from your perspective
right so as I think you know Phil hit on
something really important there which
is it's a great frontier to drive
research take to the next level how are
we going to get technologies to help
people in social situations and of
course that's incredibly important if
somebody is blind so it's harder to get
all the social cues so my contact on
that sort of thing so can technology
help them we've been doing a lot of
research about how we might push the
frontiers there and then of course it
turns out that now you take a situation
like meetings you know video conferences
where again like you said we all have
disabilities at different times of the
day in different situations and when
somebody's on the other side of the
planet and so on there are barriers to
normal communication and then some of
the research ideas apply equally in some
of these situations that you might
encounter in an office setting for
example well some of the gaming advances
we've talked about and we've even
alluded to it already here in this
conversation have come out of the annual
company-wide summer hackathon yeah but
there's a more compact version of this
held for Microsoft Research in Microsoft
gaming and it's gained quite a bit of
traction
what do you see emerging from this hack
event for researchers designers and game
developers Chris why don't you start
yeah I think of it as sort of you know
TED Conference meets hackathon it's the
kind of affair kind of a hybrid thing we
you know we've we've run a couple so far
the first one was quite conference like
had really sort of allowed everybody to
get know what was going on in the
different teams but the second one was
really high energy and it was very
focused on putting together teams from
research from gaming and just working
together on crazy little projects I mean
one little example was some developers
and the gaming teams working with
researchers using a machine learning to
take visuals from games and classify the
genre of those games just little
exercise and machine learning and a
great opportunity for people to get
their first experience of doing hands-on
learning in this very collaborative
environment but I think the real benefit
that we've seen are the new
relationships that form of people
getting to know each other and then
going on to form new collaborations so
Phil how about from your perspective
what is this annual hack event or now
semiannual yeah every six months
that's semi right I think we can't name
the conference because we use a
copyrighted name for the name of our
little internally own link that's right
intro maybe I've seen it on a t-shirt
somewhere but we will not sell those I
love the fact that the teams have so
much energy around this this isn't
something that I dictated or I think
Chris dictated that must happen it's
self driven by the team's getting
together many people flying in which is
time away from friends and family to sit
down and really just have interesting
conversations about what opportunities
are in front of us and then actually
start typing and try to make some
progress on certain things in a short
amount of time which is the kind of
hacking nature of it we started off with
the idea we're gonna do it once a year I
think after the first one there was this
we can't wait 12 more months to go do it
again so the team's self-organized again
and to go put something in place in six
months I don't think we'll get to
monthly I think we're gonna try to pin
it at six months but there's just a ton
of energy around those moments in time
and as we know the work everybody's
connected now so that work happens even
between the times where you get the
teams together but it's literally we
have to close the doors because it fills
up really quickly hmm
but it is taking our gaming teams not
just our devs on the gaming side or game
design people our artists bring them in
with our researchers and categories we
usually pick a theme and they go to a
secret spot and they just kind of have
some fun laughs and also think about
what if opportunities and I love how it
just builds on itself with the momentum
the teams have
[Music]
Chris another researcher at Cambridge
cachi Hoffman who was also a guest has
been spearheading some AI research on a
platform called project Malmo which is
based on the wildly popular game
Minecraft which you fill I think brought
into the Microsoft fold that's right and
it uses reinforcement learning to Train
agents so how's this platform enhancing
the gaming experience now and how might
it advance general human AI
collaboration in the future
right so minecraft is you know thank you
Phil that was an awesome minecraft is
fantastic when the great things about
Minecraft is such a flexible environment
you can create the simplest little world
up to something which is almost like the
real world and everything in between so
from a search point of view you can kind
of titrate the the kind of level of
challenge that you're presenting your AI
if it's too easy you just make it harder
and so last year we used minecraft under
this Malmo umbrella to launch a a
competition to allow researchers around
the world to experiment with AI in the
domain of reinforcement learning and
it's been very because of this sort of
open nature and collaborative nature
it's just brought lots and lots of
people together and that even within the
company I mean it's been a great
collaboration amongst the different MSR
labs it's not just Cambridge and can't
show you does a fantastic job of leading
this but you know our labs in Redmond
and Montreal and just bringing
researchers across Microsoft
internationally together along with the
great folks in Minecraft so I want to
shift a little over to the fact that we
live right now in a fairly console
centric world but I'm told the future of
gaming is anywhere with anyone on any
device so what role does cloud computing
play in the gaming world what can I do
for both gamers and game developers yeah
in today's world there's a little over
seven billion people on the planet about
four billion of those are connected to
the Internet in some way whether it's a
mobile phone a PC a console any other
device half the connected world plays
video games today
and if you think by 2030 analysts are
saying four out of the five billion
connected consumers at that point will
be playing games not everybody considers
themselves a gamer but you give them 20
minutes on a bus with a phone they're
probably going to start playing
something so we think about our ambition
is Microsoft what scale should we think
about we don't think it should be about
what device you own we put the player at
the center of the decisions that we make
and we say how do we bring the game's
content that you want to you on any
device how does your community move with
you from device to device and this
happens on any other you're a Netflix
customer on your PC on your phone on
your television anywhere you go you can
log in and use Spotify Netflix any
service Facebook Twitter all of these
things meet you where you are
Gaming is kind of the last bastion of
device first consumer engagement and as
Microsoft we say we won't accept that we
want to make you the owner of your
experience and you should be able to go
from device to device the issue we have
is not all the devices are technically
capable of displaying some of the rich
worlds and characters and stories that
our creators create so cloud allows us
to do the rendering of that experience
in our data centers and then bring the
video stream down literally to any
device that can decode a video and take
some input and allow people to play
anywhere and I always think this isn't
really about people who say okay I'm
gonna play while I'm away from my PC or
away from my console like yeah those
will be users but I think about people
in emerging markets where they're only
compute device will be the phone in
their pocket but the connection of the
internet means they know what a halo is
right they know what a minecraft is they
know what our brands and what our
stories and characters are and we're
pushing to bring those experiences to
the devices that they already have in
their pocket so nikunj was just talking
about the secret sauce of pre computing
and having asher manage that because
it's just so expensive in cpu yeah time
to do these big calculations that you
need for realistic games so from your
perspective crests
how does the cloud help out the work
you're doing upstream of the device
delivery Yahoo the cloud is such an
amazing innovation the sort of the
elasticity of computation the ability to
effectively put supercomputer super
super hyper computer capabilities in the
pockets as phil said of somebody in
africa effectively and this is sort of
inconceivable in the pre cloud era so
that scale of computation is incredibly
important in the backend of research
because it's driving really the
state-of-the-art in machine learning and
AI it's also really important for these
sort of rich simulated worlds I mean one
of the great technologies that comes out
of the gaming world is very rich
simulated worlds which can be used for
other kinds of things as well
reinforcement learning for you know
automata vehicles or whatever it may be
or applications in healthcare and so on
so if the cloud really plays a very
fundamental role in the ear revolution
very generally I think so the mission of
Microsoft is to quote unquote empower
every person and organization on the
planet to achieve more and it's an
interesting context putting into the
gaming world how do I achieve more in
gaming I win more I get a better social
experience there's all kinds of
interesting threads on that that you
guys have addressed that I actually
never thought of which is fantastic how
is gaming and the technical research
behind it important to the company's
mission and what is it about gaming and
gaming research that empowers people one
really interesting thing about AI and
gaming from a Microsoft perspective is
that it's not about how do we get a
computer to beat the human right how do
we achieve human-level performance in
game X game my game said as if a human
being was somehow a list of capabilities
and you're crossing off one at a time
this is you know this is a sort of much
richer view of AI as a collaboration
between people and machines effectively
how can the AI enhance the human
experience in this case you know great
more fun great more rich immersive
interesting varied gaming experiences so
in terms of empowering people it's
really part of that AI narrative of the
complementarity between
AI and people and it's true today and I
think it'll be true for a very long time
to come
there the capabilities of the machine
and the capabilities of people will be
different and they'll be complementary
and they come together in this very
it's a synthesis in the world of gaming
Phil talk to us about yeah your side I
really think about the word empower and
what does that mean to a person and I
don't think it's Microsoft's job to
define what empower means I think about
our work in the gaming space it can be
messy at times like the world can be
messy there's violence there's people
who play too often there's the
monetization how that works
one of the easy things that we could do
as a company is lean back and say okay
it's too messy we don't want to play in
that space but then when I look at our
mission statement of empowering every
person empowering every person is also
going to be a little messy every once in
a while and I love that we learn and get
the feedback through the activity of
being relevant in a space where people
are gravitating I think how many kids on
the planet their first compute
experience is picking up mom or dad's
iPad and playing Minecraft and what
responsibilities do we have as the
curators of Minecraft in that loop with
somebody the social interactions they're
gonna have when somebody comes into
their world what should that feel like
how does a five-year-old feel empowered
in that situation and what do we teach
both ourselves and the people in that
environment at those influential times
that will permeate how people work how
they interact with each other in
different social environments whether
it's physical or digital I love the
opportunity to empower and I just think
the gaming space gives us this
opportunity to empower people to achieve
more and maybe the achieve is kind of
satisfaction and fun but also to tackle
some of the issues that are out there
that are Microsoft scale opportunities
and the interaction right now between
the companies values and principles in
this space and what we want to stand for
in the gaming space I don't think I've
ever been stronger and it's I think it's
just amazing opportunity for us
so I asked all the guests that come into
this booth some version of the question
what keeps you up at night so what
should we be thinking about in the
worlds that you are responsible for
creating and shipping what keeps you up
at night
i'ma go to bed at 10 percent I'm I'm not
a high stress person I just don't work
that way but I like the question and
when I think about as the head of gaming
at Microsoft there are two sides to
anything that you do what content should
we approve what activities on the
platform are safe for others how long
should somebody play who gets to control
that how they spend as I said earlier I
want to be part of that conversation not
outside of it if we decided that we
wouldn't want to do gaming any more
gaming is not going away
so the thing that motivates me is I'd
rather be at the table and part of the
conversation than just sitting back and
pointing at it because as we started at
the beginning of all this plays in an
innate human need
people are gonna play and I think we
have a unique opportunity to be part of
that and part of that means dealing with
the hard issues the sticky issues and
the things that maybe keep us up at
night sometimes but I'd rather be
relevant in that conversation and part
of it and bring a Microsoft point of
view then outside of it just pointing at
it as something that's too hard for us I
won't accept that Chris what do you
think what keeps you up at night and
what you call a technology optimists
right I really believe in the amazing
power of technology to all kinds of
great things in the world and
particularly with technologies like AI
and really machine learning they're
ubiquitous they'll be used in many many
different places but when you have a
very powerful general technology as we
know there are ways that it could be you
know deliberately misused but also there
are just ways in which you could
accidentally kind of get it wrong and
we've even seen in the you know the
early phases of this revolution
situations not machine gaming but areas
where people very well-intentioned
people have hit some little bumps in the
road perhaps around biases and just
unintended consequences of learning from
data but I think the good news here is
that we you know particularly Microsoft
as a company but I think we as a
community are very much on the front for
we're recognizing that there are these
obstacles these challenges and in many
cases there should become research
problems and they're very actively being
researched so again I think once we
recognize that we can be on the front
foot and really try to avoid most of
those well this has been a fascinating
conversation and it's not quite over yet
cuz I have one more question but I want
to thank you guys both for this
eye-opening Venn diagram overlap
descriptions of this world so here's
your chance to talk to would-be
researchers and developers who are also
gaming enthusiasts out there I love this
quote from Satya he says we don't want
to be the cool company in the tech
sector we want to be the company that
makes other people cool I don't know if
he actually said that but if he didn't
he should have what's on the horizon for
the future of gaming and why is
Microsoft a good place for the cool kids
to be so I actually think of three
things here that I just love to see come
out of this I mean the first one is
seeing this amazing collaboration really
driving the frontiers of AI we're seeing
this already new algorithms new
techniques for machine learning being
driven by the challenges that arise in
the world of gaming so that's the first
one and then the second one is to see
the flow of ideas in the other direction
to see that we're really impacting the
world of gaming creating rich new
experiences and just do wonderful things
for hundreds of millions of people if
not billions of people around the world
that's an amazing opportunity and then
even the third one is even more
ambitious to see this amazing
collaboration lead to things that spill
over and spin out into other fields and
the healthcare one is a particularly
exciting one so we're you know really
quite ambitious Phil how about you yeah
I think that maybe we can be the cool
kids and make others cool at the same
time the opportunity to put our customer
whether the customer is a developer the
people using our products at the center
is really what I hear from saty it's not
about our gratification and the work
that we do its what impact does that
have on others I think that is such a
pivot for us Microsoft for a long time
has been centered on what we do and
maybe how we do it now we're getting
more and more focused on why we do what
we do but I love that transformation
that I've seen inside the company I
think so much of the work that's going
on right now just has application that
we see today but also
application that we don't see tomorrow
and that's why I think the ongoing work
for all these developers on lean in and
learn hmm growth mindset I can kind of
tick off our cultural principles but I
think that we have such a rich place to
go learn from and some incredible people
to learn from like Chris and I am the
team at MSR is just awesome and I love
that opportunity is such a great thing
about working here that's just a great
chance to say a huge thank you to fill
in your amazing team and I you know it's
been a fantastic collaboration I really
just love to see this carry on for many
years to come
great thanks Chris and as it turns out
cool is not a zero-sum game we can be
cool you can be cool we can all be cool
and you guys you guys are really cool so
thanks to both of you Chris and Phil for
making time to share your insights on
the podcast today great to have you both
here in person thank you the questions
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Chris Bishop and
Phil Spencer's and how Microsoft takes
playing games seriously visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]